should we get on trt
I don't know let's see here's the blood
work bro yeah how's your dick function
you have morning wood still
yeah okay yeah libido solid yeah how can
you tell if you're libido solid you like
you still want to have sex you want a
pork oh yeah yeah yeah so are you saying
if you don't have those things then
that's like your symptoms like maybe
looking into things further I got my
testosterone levels checked they're fine
what are they though uh I have it right
here
what would you guess just buy it I don't
know just by like how cool I am you
could have super high test but if you
don't lift or you know eat properly you
can still look like nothing so well I
mean like clearly you know I'm like an
alpha yeah
yeah yeah
Derek's really afraid of you yeah
exactly yeah I mean clearly My fasting
glucose is 90. okay my liver health is
30. that is not an accurate statement
what you just said why because that's
not a marker you're just saying my liver
health is 30.
alt okay you have to remember Cody AST
is 22. okay are those good or bad it's
not bad yeah when Cody sees commercials
he believes everything so he went and
got one of these like you know
it's not actual like it's all displayed
all pretty it's like I said he will fall
for any scam this is just some guy
putting numbers into charts was this
like a sponsor or somebody you went and
paid for like what is this he paid this
no no no this is just like my doctor
I just pay I pay for this like private
doctor uh service if you want really
elaborate blood work I could get you uh
I do want to do that okay I think like
is that beneficial even for someone
who's like not on drugs just to like
figure out yeah here you are for me even
if you're somebody who is doing nothing
and you think you're totally healthy I
think getting a baseline elaborate panel
is always warranted because then if
something gets [ __ ] up you can then
retroactively assess what went awry and
is causing you to be this way now I
actually would like to do the same
because uh my old man got the Big C
cancer and uh he could have maybe caught
it if he when he notices test levels
down a little bit yeah I'll get you guys
an elaborate panel my company is called
Miracle it's like full preventative
medicine yeah oh nice oh yeah our man
how are things going business-wise
really good yeah wait hold up this valid
it's not even a joke now what you're our
doctor
exactly yeah can we do this yeah no yeah
I'm not kidding yeah I'll get it for you
[ __ ] yeah I'm stoked yeah my uh my
only two
like blood panels I hesitate to even
call them that but I went and got my
test checked two times and the scores
were so variably different that I have
no clue what I actually have yeah the
problem is there's so little information
around this stuff too like for example
like the difference between free test
and total tests even the time of day you
get the test get massively yeah what
your level is yeah so it's just it's a
snapshot in time of what's going on
right now but that could be influenced
by a myriad of factors that you have to
have the context on to actually develop
a more informed assessment of your
current state of health and so your plan
your panel accounts for that yeah okay
and even if you had even if you had a
low test level we would be able to look
upstream and see why do you have the low
test is it because of uh sub-optimal
signaling from your brain to your testes
or your testes literally unresponsive
because they're different some people
haphazardly get on trt they don't
actually need it and they end up reliant
on it you know forever because some
doctor who wanted prescribe them
something and make a markup on a
medication because once you're on it
you're like pretty much on it for life
so it's a pretty good like passive
Revenue model interesting so you know
some clinics exist to just like
prescribe [ __ ] and they'll be like oh
you know you don't feel great you have a
300 tests it's not great for your age
you should probably get on get on this
forever wow dude so why are you on it
forever once you're on it
um stop producing it if you actually
clinically need it you otherwise would
have had a sub-optimal state of health
without it so it's kind of like
necessary it's not necessary but it
could be depending on how bad of a state
of health you're in and then when you're
on it though it shuts down the signal
from your brain to your testes and
that's why you end up with shriveled
atrophy testes if you're on it and
there's stuff you could do to maintain
testicular function to ensure that when
you want to have a kid you still have
fertility which is like more nuanced but
yeah it's uh very much just
understanding that stuff and when you
become when you start using it yeah you
you're shutting down that signal so so
um your body no longer produces the
natural signaling to your testy that it
would have otherwise if you weren't on
it so you you are essentially reliant on
synthetic hormones at that point is that
why you're why are you on it because of
all the you know the bodybuilding in the
past all the uh drug cocktails and stuff
I kind of just transitioned to like a
replacement model and as you get into
your 30s like for me I could you know I
could potentially try and come off but
it would be a relatively arduous
recovery process that right now is not
really conducive to well you got a lot
of [ __ ] going on so trying to
reconfigure your body at this time when
you're trying to do all this work might
be yeah a rough go yeah and again like
back in the day too it would have been
nice to know like some of the things
around maintaining testicular function
while you're using the gear like not a
lot of people talked about things like
maybe you've heard of it maybe not HCG
while you're using your test yeah it's
uh it basically is a synthetic it's a
memetic of the signal from your brain to
your test is to produce testosterone so
you could
by using it concurrently with its
testosterone replacement therapy keep
your testes producing what it would have
otherwise if you still had natural
function while also using the exogenous
testosterone yeah but they didn't tell
you that so everyone just walked around
with shriveled balls that they could
have otherwise avoided my balls are too
saggy so yeah yeah they could use a
little shriveling that's why yeah I've
always got to pick them up in the
morning so you know yeah I think I got
some sack to give have you you don't
hear Rich Piana is yes yeah have you
ever heard a statement about why small
balls are good no
I would butcher it if I said it but just
look it up Rich Piana small balls and
see what comes up
steroids make your balls straight wait
just subtle note doesn't he have a
similar vocal tone as Stevo yeah
it's it's always [ __ ] me up the answer
is yes they do but
let me throw this at you is that really
a bad [ __ ] thing I don't know let's
break this [ __ ] down
I got Kirsten here I got a question for
you so would you prefer to see
a dick hanging lower than the balls or
[ __ ] balls hanging lower than the
dick
hang lower than the balls of course you
would rather see a dick hang lower than
the balls now
some guys are blessed and have big
[ __ ] dicks and some guys are [ __ ]
and have little [ __ ] dicks so
the guy said this guy is spitting fast
yeah dude he's convincing you to get on
gear dude that's what he's doing I'm
crying at every little dick dude who is
a fan of him up until this point and
they watched him say that sentence and
they're like
yeah like I just have to just take that
[ __ ] on the chin like I bet they're like
yeah I mean it's it's true yeah you know
I feel like he's being kind of
empathetic no he is no guys are [ __ ]
that's what I mean like they're just
like relating to him like speak that
[ __ ] Rich yeah it's like man you're
right just we are kind of [ __ ] talk
your [ __ ] Rich having balls hanging down
below your dick is not the best look and
it only makes your dick look even
smaller than it is so I love he's
breaking this down yeah like it's a
complicated like Theory you know yeah
oh man dude this is too good you just
heard it from a hot girl and I guarantee
you every [ __ ] girl out there is
gonna say the same [ __ ] thing they'd
rather see the dick hanging lower than
the balls having the balls shrink maybe
20 to 30 percent is probably a good
[ __ ] thing in fact not probably it is
a good [ __ ] thing
God damn it dude that's the hardest
hitting two minutes I've seen on YouTube
in like a little while man it's really
good and I love how every other word is
[ __ ] I know there was like prank
videos that stemmed out of this where
people would go into universities and
just play this as loud as they could
without any holes and stuff that's
hilarious and all the dudes that lift
are like Rich yes yeah this [ __ ] they
hear the Battle Cry dude